gun violence in america  for those you think of this from an  economic standpoint listening to me  estimated to cost the nation 280  billion let me say it again 280  billion dollars a year you say how could  that be joe  hospital bills physical therapy  trauma counseling legal fees prison  costs  and the loss of productivity  not to mention a psychological damage  done to the children who live in these  cities  watching this happen knowing someone it  happened to  this gun violence in our neighborhood is  having profound impact  on our children even if they're never  involved  in pulling the trigger or being the  victim of  on the other side of a church for a  fraction of the cost  of gun violence we can save lives  create safe and healthy communities and  build economies that work for  all of us and save  billions of american dollars